around what's this about rules for paws
and sons there was a time
not that long ago when prime time
television in the u.s
looked a lot like this
but today it looks a lot more like this
i love you this shift can be traced back
to a revolutionary moment in programming
history over
50 years ago that forever changed
television
television has long been a centerpiece
of american culture
by 1955 half of u.s households had a
television set
and by the early 1960s that figure rose
to 90
but what was popular on tv at the time
mostly variety shows
game shows soap operas westerns and
light comedies
wasn't exactly reflective of the
contemporary world
there were some major events unfolding
during the 1960s
uh including probably most
uh predominant for a lot of people was
the ongoing war in vietnam
there was also the continuation
of racial justice uh civil rights
so with entertainment the
comfort food shall we say of the
especially the 1960s was silly the
default
for entertainment was to
not rock the boat to be reassuring
i'm having trouble enough believing a
toaster that works when you say
five but a square rig that's ridiculous
it's important to remember that in that
era there were three main forces of
television
uh cbs nbc and abc
there was no cable option
for the vast majority of the country
there was no satellite there was no
streaming
there wasn't even the ability to record
a show to watch later
so essentially when you were talking
about watching television
you were watching the curated offerings
of three major commercial forces
whose number one motivation was to make
the most money possible
and for cbs in particular at the
beginning
of the 1960s they
had struck gold with rural
comedy the andy griffith show is
definitely
the most popular um that kind of started
the craze for cbs in 1960
uh followed by the beverly hillbillies
in 1962.
um then you have petticoat junction in
1963
gomer pyle usmc in 64
and then green acres in 1965 and that's
comprises the core of the rural craze
all of these very popular series had
something in common
they featured stereotypically country
characters
in silly anodyne situations miles
removed from the tensions of civil
rights at home
and war abroad and there wasn't a person
of color
anywhere in sight aaron rubin who was a
producer of
the andy griffith show and a couple of
these others he said you know people
are watching the show to escape and if
they see
people of color they think of
unrest they think of troubles and we
don't want them to be thinking about
problems we want them to be happy
and so that's why we're only showing
white people as a business though
the reason cbs was going to favor the
comfort food was that it had worked
it had worked since certainly since the
beginning of the 60s
why in the world would there be a
thought of even changing that
there's a couple of things going on in
the late 60s that are going to lead to
some pretty big changes
for one thing the demographics that you
see
with television are changing and they're
getting much more sophisticated the baby
boom generation
is starting to come to adulthood and
they
are now the targeted consumers and so
you need to not only
get that coveted 18 to 35 demographic
but there's a serious generation gap
between their parents and this group in
addition to shifting demographics
the major networks were facing a
deadline to make significant
changes to their lineups new regulations
in 1970
required local tv stations to reduce the
number of hours that
big network shows were given during
evening prime time
in order to foster more diversity of
local and independent programming
this forced reshuffling presented the
major networks and opportunity for
transformation
in a radical move meant to catapult cbs
ahead of its competitor networks
the company appointed a 33-year-old vice
president
fred silverman to lead the charge which
he did bringing about a revolution in
programming
on a scale that no network had ever
attempted before
his first target rural comedies rural
comedy came under fire for this a little
bit at the time because they're on the
air at a point when you are starting to
see
uh people starting to talk about
diversification and saying okay maybe we
you know this doesn't really reflect
what america looks like
maybe we should put some people of color
on here maybe we should
you know spread our wings a little bit
and explore some different kinds of
stories
cbs under silverman's direction did just
that
wiping most of the rural comedies from
the slate and introducing new shows that
were unlike
anything that had been seen on
television before
[Music]
i don't do no more of that america's
favorite family
is at it again all the family was the
breakout hit
if god had meant us to be together he'd
have put us together but look what he'd
done
he put you over in africa he put the
rest of us in all the white countries
well you must have told him where we
were cause somebody came and got it
maude uh a fiercely independent
older one i think it's going to cause a
lot of you had
good times which was uh
a black family in chicago how high is it
now jj
i don't know therma but it says to be
continuing next to marmothe
you had the next door neighbors to
archie
bunker george jefferson move on up to
the city
and have their own
program how can you afford to live in a
place like this
you ain't tall enough to be no
basketball player
and the lead performers were black
performers
and it was a joyful
in the celebration of their own identity
cbs wasn't the only network aboard the
revolution
nbc also launched new groundbreaking
series in the early 70s
like san fernando and the flip wilson
show the first
variety show with an african-american
host thanks y'all i can't tell you how
much i appreciate that
fine ovation initial reactions to the
programming shift were
not surprisingly mixed as actor pat
boutrum of green acres famously remarked
cbs cancelled every show that had a tree
in it
president richard nixon and some other
conservative members of congress
criticized shows like on the family for
being well in their opinion
not family-friendly
[Music]
but all controversy aside the popularity
of silverman's new lineup for cbs
demonstrated that networks could take a
risk in targeting new audience segments
and still be successful that was
something that would not have been
on the schedule prior to
the the rural purge this was
an opportunity for success and nothing
drives
programming decisions on television more
than financial success
and when you're talking about these
programs being top five or
number one winning their time slots and
so forth
then that means that's where we want to
go that's what we want to copy
and it changed the attitudes
of what was acceptable and it changed
the
options and opportunities in the
immediate
aftermath of that success despite its
ominous name
the rural purge didn't mean the end of
all rural oriented programming
first off many of the prime time series
cancelled by cbs didn't disappear
they simply lived on in syndication in
reruns
but the networks also recognized that
they still had to cater to important
rural and southern demographics
cbs is gonna throw the rural comedy
audience
a bone to some extent in 1971 they are
christmas special
about the waltons and that turns out to
be so popular that they create the show
the waltons which is going to be very
popular for that network
for a good portion of the 1970s the
legacy is you can succeed
in many different ways and you could
choose to try to appeal to
everybody or you could try to carve out
portions which you can profitably
program to and in effect
create multiple channels of viewing
not just multiple channels of
opportunity
for people behind the scenes if you
start tracking
from the 70s into contemporary times
we're talking about multiple decades
here nonetheless
what we're looking at is more and more
people saying
i want to do this how can i do this
the answer has arrived in the form of
new television streaming platforms
which have access to a quantity of data
that was inconceivable during the first
era of television
tv networks largely relied on a third
party provider like nielsen to give them
sort of samples of what people were
watching you know nielsen would measure
based on a subset of the population and
extrapolate from that
to not guess but to give a
an estimate of how many people were
actually watching um
you know most of these streaming
services know to the person
how many people are watching a show at a
given time or in a week or in a month
um they know what they're watching they
know what whether they you know
how they interact with um the interface
are they
opening a title and watching it for two
minutes and then stopping
after they finish one title what do they
go to next it gives them a lot more
information and data to decide what is
and is not working i think that in the
past couple of years diversity has
become
more and more important i'd say and part
of that is just because as you become
something that you want everybody to
watch you need to make something that
appeals to everybody i think a lot of
these services
they're started by appealing to
wealthy people on the coast of the
united states
probably majority white you know they
were going for netflix early on with
sort of the hbo model where you want to
make a show that wins awards
and appeals to you know people who live
in beverly hills and west hollywood and
soho and things like that
as it's gotten bigger and it's speaking
to more and more the population
you've seen that it is you know telling
stories from
um from all backgrounds and in
particular i mean one of the things that
that's almost entirely new to streaming
is these services are global
and so not only is is a company like
netflix trying to speak
to people of all creeds and color
in the united states you know the
majority of their viewers
are in the long run potentially going to
be non-white
um you know they're trying to reach
people in india they're trying to reach
people in korea they're trying to reach
people in japan they're trying to reach
people in
throughout europe throughout latin
america all these people have slightly
different tastes and it means that in
addition
to you know making shows from a diverse
group of creators in the us
that they are funding shows from an even
more diverse group of creators outside
of the us and in many cases it's because
of of what tastes are during the time of
the rural purge
you had limited access to limited
resources of
information and entertainment now that's
flipped
and you actually have to make a
conscious decision
to turn off to filter the
the many resources that are offered to
you
decades later the legacy of the rural
purge is more relevant than ever
that representation in diversity in
media not only matters for society
but also makes good business sense by
taking a risk that ultimately paid off
cbs and the other networks ushered in a
media landscape
that more closely mirrored the faces and
values of our entire society
and we have that moment in history to
thank for the rich
and diverse array of programming that is
offered by the channels of today
and undoubtedly tomorrow
you